President Trump says fire and fury may
not be enough to deter North Korea the
president is raising his rhetoric in the
face of a possible missile strike
targeting the u.s. territory of Guam the
president said North Korea faces quote a
whole new ballgame and will not get away
with threatening the u.s. major Garrett
is near the trump National Golf Club in
New Jersey where the president answered
questions yesterday major good morning
good morning president Trump heard the
criticism of fire and fury read the
stories about dissension in his
administration so he pressed ahead
trying to turn the tables on Kim jong-un
by making him worry about what the u.s.
might do instead of the other way around
the people that were questioning that
statement was it too tough maybe it
wasn't tough enough president Trump's
language was blunt and vaguely menacing
North Korea better get their act
together were they going to be in
trouble like few nations ever have been
in trouble North Korea said it was
planning a four missile strike near the
u.s. territory of Guam as a warning the
Pentagon said he will not fortify the US
military base there he does something in
Guam it will be an event the likes of
which nobody's seen before reporters
asked if that was a dare he's not going
to go around threatening Guam and he's
not going to threaten the United States
and he's not going to threaten in Japan
and he's not going to threaten South
Korea no that's not a dare as you say
that is a statement of fact
the president vowed to maintain the
world's strongest nuclear force no
matter the cost
he also said he would prefer no nuclear
weapons and the complications they or
their pursuit present in North Korea
Pakistan and Iran
I'd like to de nuke the world I would
like Russia and the United States and
China and Pakistan and many other
countries that have nuclear weapons get
rid of them in California defense
secretary James of mattis said the
Pentagon can confront North Korea but
diplomats for now are in the lead my
responsibility
is to have military options should they
be needed you can see the American
effort is diplomatically led it has
diplomatic traction and is gaining
diplomatic results the president said he
doubts this latest round of sanctions
against North Korea will succeed and he
tried to entice more cooperation from
China with a prospect of better trade
deals if they help out on North Korea
playing an economic card for the first
time since this crisis intensified flat
major thank you